hello
i'm alexander ceo of sandbox geometry
i want to talk with you today about a
quantum level parametric geometry i use
to construct and bond
like atoms together it all begins with
curved space central force mechanics
i explore central force curve space
using a computer-based mechanical
contrivance called a curse-based
division assembly
take code for a unit circle add code for
a unit parabola and we have a parametric
csda
what makes the csva perfect for shaping
central force energy curves is the
dependent curve initial focal radius p
is congruent with the pi over 2 spin
radius of the independent curve at
inception i can now track central force
spherical happenings using a square
space profile f of r
counting with infinities i realized
earlier the unit circle could be
population curvature beyond the
circumferential
boundary lay radii of curvature a
working central force csta
so even on outside the boundary of
curvature we have
unit one macro infinity unit 2 macro
infinity unit 3 mac
on and on and on and on
fits perfectly for a basic g field
orbital r
f of r for position position energy zer
isaac's displacement radius and
tracking displacement energy on the
dependent period time curve
my i use the s and t 1
stands for space and time square 1 is
what i use to
analyze and construct massive g field
space curve
i use book book and position vectors to
define energy limits of an orbit period
i use energy tangent slope to determine
orbit velocity
the curve time diagonal has a complete
history of orbit curvature let's
build a space-time square for the uh
earth and moon
i reference orbit uh
orbit curve limits as high energy and
low energy not perihelion after an
effigy and perigee
we're going to have to convert the
squares
kilometric squarespace parameters
the green column into unit numbers for
uh
ratios of the csca reference frame the
orange column
the way we're going to do it you're
going to take the average radius 384
400 units and that's going to be the
denominator of all comparatives
on the numerator we're going to put all
the event parameters
and you multiply everything outside the
unit circle by two
and everything on the unit circle and in
the unit circle has potential to
multiply by one
now the lattice rectum and sir isaac
newton universal law
all orbit curves this is a profile of a
csva
all orbit curves are relative with the
energy on the system lattice spectrum
diameter
this high energy curve and low energy
curve and the lattice rectangular
diameter
is the average energy and of the orbit
itself now what i want to do i'm going
to use that fact
i'm going to change sir isaac newton
universal law just a little bit down
here
m1 and m2 are will never change in our
lifetime and
and roll them in with the constant of
proportionality g
we now have k times one over r squared
which is the constant of proportionality
times the curvature squared and we just
got to saying that the unit circle i
like to use it because that's a
population of curvature
so now we want to construct the radius
this is a high energy
orbit curve one thing you'll notice with
csdas
orbit energy motion energy curves
maintain
contact with what i call a curved space
directrix
and always contact with the field
potential now there's two ways of
getting this curve
one is the basic subtraction we know
what the focal radius is going to be
that focal radius is up here
1.8932 we also know the potential curve
is one
so you take one away from the poker
radius you're going to have a radius
energy curve for 0.8932 units
we can also use sir isaac newton's
universal law
the event curvature is 1.8902 the
curvature evaluation for that would be
1 over 1.8902 squared times
4 the lattice rectum the lattice rectum
of every curve space and now
analytics is the constant of
proportionality now this is a curvature
term you have to invert it to get the
radius
the radius turns out to be of the energy
curve 0.8932
which is what we had up here
now this is a low energy curve and this
is the energy tangent
that changes slope and gives us the
velocity of the various
orbitals i have put something new in
here it's called an
insulator tangent the insulator tangent
i use to keep
separate the opposing forces of
attraction and escape which every
gravity field
seems to have and now that what's here
is the event radius
to here to the spin radius we see that
the
insulator tangent and the energy tangent
intercept at exactly one half
the radius showing that equal
distribution
of energy orbit energy across space of
half the potential
after motion it's a zero sum perfectly
balanced system
and it goes on for millions and millions
of years
this we're doing the same thing again i
got an insulator tangent this is a high
energy tangent
and it meets here in the middle of the
displacement radius from ac
the displacement radius for this
construction but
i'm explaining that the motive energy
curves change shape now the previous one
the low energy curve was bigger than
this the high energy curve is a lot
smaller
they change shape to accommodate
conserved angular momentum experience by
changing orbit event radius
lines and curves with quantum structures
i wondered i i'd start i was somewhere i
wondered about constructing a dependent
parabola curve within the unit circle
and it did fit perfectly now this is not
a unit circle
this now is the radius two unit we're
looking at quantum
type structures in fact it's a helium
atom
i weight the electron cloud with a z
number
so this is a helium atom and they
construct the unit curve in here the
binding parabolic hole and it
fits perfectly leg to leg on the spin
location
of the atom itself
i work two c s d a relative c s a space
in time square that's
s and t two is for micro infinity
realm of curvature quantum phone s and t
one we just went over with gravity
macro space radius of curvature note two
dependent parabola curve one red
and one blue unify one spin and rotation
axis across both infinities
well we have motion and the g-field
motion that was easy enough that's
gravity field they uh
is visible and can be measured with time
but what are we kind of what kind of
mechanical energy we're going to look
for in uh
at the quantum level at the nuclear
level i'm going to be used
i will be concerned with thermodynamics
my geometry is going to be concerned and
trying to read nuclear temperature
stress
now bonding of two elements a latent
heat sensible heat and saturation
these are very important terms in
refrigeration
bonding of two elements will require
temperate cooperation
this slide defines terms i will use to
monitor nuclear thermal happening
sensible heat can be construed as an
elementary step function
of calculus this is solid sulfur state
solid slope of state liquid and slope of
state gas
to climb or fall one degree temperature
on slopes of state
require one calorie of thermal energy in
or out to get it done
direct attention to both plateaus
from the beginning to end of either
plateau thermal energy is still being
absorbed or relinquished without change
in temperature flatline
thermal energy activity is called latent
heat
latent heat cannot be sensed as it is
the energy required by the nucleus
to leak the bounds of perceived state
though we cannot meter latent heat we
can watch it as evidenced by
saturation glass of water is a great
example saturation is a quasi-mix
of solid and liquid or liquid and gas
the two red lines meter
a chronological medium median uh middle
middle ground for both saturation event
saturation event one
changes the fixed shape of a solid into
the variable shape of a liquid
at your end it marks the place in time
and space for one half solid and one
half liquid
saturation event two changes
the fixed volume of a liquid into the
variable volume of a gas and marks
the place in time and space for half
liquid and half gas saturation
exploring fusion and vaporization using
space and time 2.
s t 2 has a linear diagonal connecting
nuclear corner
e right here and the e cloud corner
f the diagonal produced
links nuclear rotation and spin a
and b with the quantum quarters of snt-2
i use this co-linear geography to meter
nuclear latent heat happenings
note the event five happening on the
closed neighborhood j
shaped with the initial focal radius p
this is the initial focal radius from
here to here
j does so by reading thermal
registration from rotation
thermal registration from spin and
thermal registration from the quantum
corners
of snt-2 it's all collected at event
five
if all four registers rotation spin
nuclear corner and e-cloud corner read
fusion or vaporization
environment this atom is transition
ready to change phase
latent heat thermometers we need a
thermometer a nuclear thermometer to see
what also see what's going on down there
let the levee the heavy fuel line with
the base x
designate my lithium latent heat
thermometer
it's also congruent with the positive y
axis here this is what i'm talking about
this is a late thermometer
the thermometer is linear congruent
twice with nuclear spin
each side of the liquid boundary
separating solids and gas
nuclear thermal energy disturbance in
the neighborhood of k
any thermal energy operating in here is
going to affect the thermometer much the
same as temperature will change volume
column in a liquid pole thermometer
when moving
across liquid phases temperate stress on
element population in this
particular model can be vapor or fusion
depending on whether it's going hot or
cold or cold or hot
latent heat thermometers register this
temperature stress signaling when
vibration oscillation chaos of rotation
spin and smt2 quantum corners are
sufficient to transition perceived state
for a single atom
there is a sixth collinear event a
nuclear stress hyperbola
the stress hyperbola asymptote has an
interesting intercept for the nuclear
latent heat thermometer and that's the
abscissa
is going to be z number over the number
of minus one
and the ordinance going to be the number
squared over the number minus one
for our lithium atom which we're working
with right here
it's going to be the excess is going to
be 3 over 2 and the order is going to be
9 over 2. this is
at event f the sixth event orchestrates
transition
resonance of an entire population when
all atoms of the collection read the
same registration boundaries of fusion
or vaporization
and experience nucleus stress
asymptote intercept with their internal
latency thermometer
then and only then will the entire group
population flip
perception of state
nuclear construction protocol
constructing atom1 all nuclear
parameters sourced from protein as a
primitive for all standard
to begin any element construction we
need the binding parabola focus g
close neighborhood j and the positive
lattice rectum over radius
endpoint location c coordinate c
will provide all the information we need
i want c because i'm going to
i'm interested in constructing tangents
to a curve
so we need the first derivative for
protein the answer is going to be -2t
every lattice rectum chord meets the
curve loci with endpoint slope m a
plus or minus one we want the first quad
down e tangent so set the first
derivative minus two t to the minus one
the answer is going to be a half
this is abscissa location of the slope
one energy tangent
substitute into the dependent term for
the ordinance and the answer is recorded
the lattice rectum endpoint
where unity tangent is half this is a
half the ordinance is three quarters and
the unit one
spin radius minus the ordinance will
give us p at one quarter so the
neighborhood j
construction parameter is one quarter
cosine t
one quarter sine t plus three quarters
constructing the nuclear quarters for
protium
e cloud corner is easy enough that's the
set of numbers over here
you have cis is always the z number and
the ordinate will always be twice the z
number
it's the nuclear corner we got to do a
little bit of analytic geometry
let one quarter be the initial focal
radius for the closed neighborhood of j
then the shaping curve near closed
neighborhood k of nucleus will be
congruent with neighborhood chain
this is protium we know it that it's the
uh
that this line is one quarter so we've
got a right triangle proportional here
and we know that p is one quarter and
t this leg t will give us the radius of
the nuclear binding energy curve
so we go down here it's one quarter
square squared equals two t squared
solve for k the answer is one over four
over two
use the radius of the nuclear binding
energy curve as the hypotenuse to find
the abscissa for the nuclear corner of s
and t2
again we're going to do the same thing
again i know this is a because this is
actually there's a very
thin line in here this is actually uh a
squaring asymptote of the shaping
hyperbola so it goes right through the
nucleus and it says
it's plus and minus one slopes on these
on these lines
so we're going to have 1 over 4 root 2
squared it's going to be 2 t squared and
the answer is going to be
1 8. so the x this is 1 8 and the
ordinance
will always be the z number plus the
abscissa so you make a common fraction
88 plus 1 8 is 9 8 is the
coordinate
constructing lithium atom number one
this construction parameters of all
period elements are a source from
protein
i use a table of protein meter to
determine parameters for the
construction
going from protein to lithium via table
parameters
the number one is hydrogen g number
three is lithium
so p for the protein is going to be one
quarter you want
p for lithium three times a quarter is
three quarters lattice direct the min
point three times a half three half
three times three quarters nine quarters
the nuclear corner three times one
eighth is three eighths three times nine
days 27 over eight
and the all-important bond ring three
times fifteen over eight forty five over
eight three times seventeen
over eight fifty one over eight take
these parameters code them put them into
construction you will have constructed
lithium atom number one
with respect to the cartesian coordinate
center
what's most important about this
construction is the shaping hyperbola
produced
and the e tangent normal produced meet
here at the bon
ring center and that provides us the
lithium bond plane
north of atom 1. you can confirm
bond ring coordinates by setting shaping
hyperbola equal to the unity tangent
normal
now we've got a determined nuclear
setter for atom
number two
shaping hyperbolas act as springs of
connect if atom two comes in too fast
because of temperate chaos
hyperbola springs collapse and restoring
energy
pushes atom2 and atom one apart bond
plane is a minimal distance of two atom
connect nuclear center atom two
is twice the ordinate atom one bond ring
the ordinance 51 over eight so twice
that's going to be 51 over four
this is atom number two constructed on
the spin axis north of atom one
three cosine t three sine t plus fifty
one over four
the nuclear shaping curve in
neighborhood k
three quarter cosine t three quarter
sine t plus fifty one over four the
nuclear binding energy carrier
wrapped by k three over four root two
cosine t 3 over 4
root 2 sine t plus 51 over 4.
and atom 2 shaping hyperbola shaping
hyperbolas are plus and minus square
root z
number squared plus t squared we want
the down curve
so it's going to be minus the z number
squared is going to be 9 plus t squared
plus 51 over 4.
those parameters allow the construction
of the shaping hyperbola for atom 2
at the south spin axis and
shaping hyperbola atom 1 meets shaping
hyperbola atoms 2 in the bond ring
center
as does the e tangent normal of atom 2
each tangent normal of atom 1.
atom 2 is joined with atom 1 they share
a common bond plane
electromagnetic phenomena of atom1 bond
with atom2
a line in quantum parametric geometry
has a width of an electron
joining two endpoints of charge positive
and negative
let the second let the e cloud have
negative potential
as such we can imagine quantum
electromagnetic potential
as plasma filaments connecting positive
and negative endpoints of charge between
the north
neighborhood p atom one red circuit
partnership with nuclear binding energy
curve k of atom two
atom two at atom one circuit is blue so
e cloud potential atom one will gather
in neighborhood
j and leave through the north spin axis
this is the red circuit
it goes to the bond ring and then from
there it connects directly to the
nuclear center of atom
two atom two e-cloud potential
collection
neighborhood j exits to the south
spin axis of atom2 this is the blue
circuit
goes to the bond ring and then hooks
directly to the nuclear center of atom
one
once bonded atom1 and atom2 potential
use their shaping hyperbolas to leave
ecloud space
the surface of bonded hyperbolic shaping
curves are alive with potential akin to
a van de graaff generator
atom 1 and atom two connector shared
potential across the bond ring
provide a quantum level conduit negative
charge of electron cloud
positive a partner atom nucleus center
after
separating magnetism followers from the
electric filament properties in the bond
ring
filament circuits carry phenomena
current phenomena consider elementary
right hand rule structuring magnetic
field lines surrounding the wire
conductors a nuclear right hand thumb
does
not travel a filament profile path with
the potential
but points towards terminal nuclear
centers along the spin axis
clockwise atom 2 toward atom one and
counterclockwise atom one toward atom
two
when these north and south and sourced
magnetons
meet in the bond ring they lock the
north and south magnetic attraction and
remain captured in the bond ring as pure
magnetism
becoming principal strength of bond
leaving the negative potential of the
element from an electron cloud to
connect
with the partnered atom positive charge
nucleus
magnetism is the gripping phenomena of
bond the stripping of electricity and
magnetism into separate single entities
they happen to be
provide a natural load by doing work
producing heat
and in so doing prevent explosive
property of a direct contact the same
charge or charge to ground without load
energy consumption
that's uh completes my presentation
thanks for the opportunity
and now it's now is our time for q a if
you have any questions you can click the
raise your hand
and then alexander can allow you to
speak if you have a microphone or you
can type into the pathable chat
and he could answer any questions there
you know i have one more thing i can
show you in the mathematica
let me see if we can pull it up there's
something interesting about a cfta
if you got a few minutes uh i do i also
expose curved uh squarespace map
now this is slim spin slope and roof
what i've done here is constructed the
fifth root of 13.
what's interesting to me is that the
square space is zero is a polynomial to
find
uh the roots first face zero's slope
it is amazing now these two solution
curves are coming in from the negative
side of spin
they zero flat flat line at the poles
and then they die for the solution roof
this here is an abscissa identity for
the fifth root of 13.
and um even indices do the same thing
but we have two solutions with even
indices
one on each side of negative and
positive spin this
is uh it does come up and it will always
they always flat line go to zero and
then they go
finding their solution roots where they
came from or where they're going
just some of the interesting stuff that
i i find working with these first place
and addicts i really
really get into it i enjoy
you